happy Tuesday reject nation its Greg
Alba here woke up this morning took a
shower to discover that Ant Man and the
wasp trailer has dropped here we go
people I'm not gonna talk anymore I
thought the first one was such an
underrated Marvel movie
[Music]
oh snap
Anthony
[Music]
areas as cool as like Godzilla
[Music]
yes oh she looks great man it's so eat
[Laughter]
I just have one question I guess we'll
never know but if you had you'd have
never been caught sure
I love that take your pill take who get
it see at ease and Laurence Fishburne
he's in DC EU and MCU and it's a cool
[Music]
damn dude she looks great
[Music]
gave her wings in blasters
[Music]
do you that film looks like so much fun
I really feel like they've amped up the
action a lot it's weird because when I
think about the first ant-man I usually
think about the comedy and how enjoyable
and funny it was and in here I'm looking
at the action sequences and the action
sequences look really cool I love it
this is called ant-man and the wasp
because I don't recall any other Marvel
movie really promoting the sidekick or
the partner in the film I know there's
like Captain America Winter Soldier but
that was burning the villain of that
movie here calling ant-man and the wasps
they're promoting a new team a new duo
and it's the first time we've had that I
know Gardens the galaxy is a team
initially introduced but to have ant-man
in the solo of mission and then have a
man and the wasp in the next one and the
lost their powers look cool [ __ ] swings
and blasters man Evangeline Lilly she
looks like she kicks major ass in this
trailer dude and I like to set up with
this film tear that it takes place where
after the events of Civil War Scott Lang
is under some kind of like house arrest
but now him and the team are fugitives
which makes the adventure all it more
exciting especially when the first one
was a heist film in a way and now this
one is a fugitive film in a way they're
still doing that thing where they cross
genres with each other and you get some
little teases of the villain ghosts in
here I don't know much about ghosts you
see that one shot after a man's rising
water kind of like a monster in Godzilla
it's pretty funny man and also though
like a shudder hand effect part I was
really digging the soundtrack to this
trailer the action looks great the humor
still looks on point
everything about this looks like they
amped it up and will probably have a
more solid defining film than the first
ant-man because I know what the first a
man went through a change of riders and
a change of directors this one seems to
have a different type of cinematography
to it this is coming out in July I guess
they've spoiled that earth is still
around after infinity war damn trailer
spoiling every little thing right and I
hope that they use Laurence Fishburne to
good effect you know because he only has
like a split-second of a moment in the
trailer all I know is he's like an old
friend of Hank Pym or like an old
assistant or something I imagine you
know provide some scientific knowledge
or information to help out with
something even if it's a tiny role that
he gets to make it
impactful one in this movie I know
Michael Pena was barely in the trailer
too but I hope to get more Michael Pena
and some orange slices references
alright guys well thanks for tuning in
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification better get
notified every time one of our videos is
up and also check out our patreon page
we do full-length TV show reactions and
music video reactions over there and
download and follow us in the Stardust
app posting regularly over there
30-second reactions to any film TV show
or trailer exit outro whatever